- Rewrite each fraction
with a denominator of 10.
So we have two fractions,
three fifths and seven halves
and we wanna take their
denominators of five and two
and change them to be a
common denominator of 10.
Lets start with three fifths
and we can look at this visually.
Here we can use this rectangle
to represent a whole,
one whole.
To show three fifths of
that whole, we're gonna need
to divide it into fifths
or five equal pieces.
Lets do that.
Try to make these
as equal as possible.
We have three pieces, and then finally,
there we go.
So, these should represent
five equal pieces, or fifths.
To show three fifths,
we need to shade three
of those five pieces.
So, one, two, three of those five pieces
should be shaded in to show three fifths.
We've decided we don't
want fifths anymore.
Now, we want tenths.
We want a new denominator of 10.
To change this fraction over here,
to change this to be tenths,
we need to split each
of these fifths in half.
We need to double the amount of pieces.
We can do that here.
Now, instead of fifths,
or five equal size pieces,
we have tenths.
We have one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
We found a way to have
tenths without changing
the amount that's represented.
The same amount is still
shaded, but now we have tenths.
Our denominator doubled.
We multiplied it be two, we
have twice as many pieces.
But look at what happened
to our numerator,
instead of three pieces, now we have
one, two, three, four, five, six pieces.
It also doubled.
It also was multiplied by two,
because if we double all of the pieces,
well then the shaded
ones will also double.
Each of those pieces also split in two,
so now there's twice
as many shaded pieces.
So, three fifths can be
rewritten as six tenths.
Three fifths is equal to six tenths,
and again, we didn't change the fraction.
We didn't change how much was shaded.
Three fifths and six tenths
represented the same amount.
We just changed the denominator
and wrote it a different way.
So, three fifths can be rewritten
in tenths as six tenths.
Now, for seven halves, we
again want a denominator of 10.
So, we can draw it out, or we
could try to use this pattern
we just noticed up here to
figure out how to make halves
turn into tenths.
To get from fifths to
tenths we had to double,
or multiply by two.
To get from halves to tenths,
we'd have to multiply each of our pieces
times five.
Each of our halves would
be split into five pieces.
So, we multiply two
times five to get tenths.
Like the pattern showed us up here,
if the denominator is
multiplied by a number,
we multiply the numerator
by the same number.
Those shaded pieces would
also be split five times.
We multiply our seven times five also.
You should match the
numerator and denominator
are multiplied by the same number.
Seven times five is 35.
So 35 tenths is equal to seven halves.
To change these two fractions
to have a common denominator
of 10,
three fifths will become six tenths,
and seven halves will become 35 tenths.